you know you always made me feel better
about not having a man in my life
exactly up to you and alleys that is
patricia richardson reuniting with her
old home improvement hubby Jim Allen
tonight on Last Man Standing the first
time that we talked to them was actually
24 years ago on that classic comedy and
says this is flashback Friday well we
took them back to tool time we're here
tonight taping our 100th episode of home
improvement look at these cute babies
I look like my younger brother that's
just it's a bit depressing ah it's not
that bad Tim and we should know he was
there for the first-ever taping of home
improvement back in 1991 are you saying
the car's not running
we now own a 4,000 pound four-door
Boulder we're just so much fun I said we
would just crack up I mean and just lose
it and not be able to get it together
this is a closed set except to you of
course one of the most watched it comes
of the 90s the show launched the career
of one Pamela Anderson and made Tim
Allen a household name and when we first
met the boys get this Jonathan Taylor
Thomas was 10 Zachery ty Brian was 9 and
Taryn Noah Smith was all of 7 years old
why ship by air oh this is my ship if it
was issue I see Zach quite a bit because
he's kind of works with my oldest
daughter and they said they've kind of
hooked up in the production business
I see Debbie Dunning a lot and I see
Richard Charlie they play coffee and
Rick played golf together online now
Patricia and Tim are working together
again she's reprising her role as Tim's
neighbor on his show last man standing
we both you know matured a little bit
but nothing it's like being her own
family I think he matured a lot he's
very mature very mature